[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PAPER RUSTLING]
[ROBOT NOISES]
ANNOUNCER: Welcome to the
2017 Google Play Awards.
Please welcome Purnima
Kochikar, Director of Apps
and Games Business
Development, Google Play.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR:
Good evening and
welcome to the second
annual Google Play Awards.
We launched these
awards last year at I/O
to celebrate your amazing work.
Behind every great app
is a creative vision
and a remarkable team.
Today we celebrate you,
your vision, and your teams.
It's a privilege
for us at Google
to be part of your amazing work.
You build beautiful apps,
successful businesses,
and touch lives of
people around the world.
And you challenge us to
innovate on our platforms
and keep pace with
your imagination.
I couldn't be more excited about
the diversity of the nominees
in today's categories.
From apps that
teach kids to code,
to ones that allow you to play
with friends around the world.
From fintech to
feeding the hungry,
it is amazing to see the
many different countries you
come from and the many,
many different apps that you
are building.
And, as where I stand,
it is exciting for me
to also see all the wonderful
things that connect you.
You have a relentless
focus on your users,
innovation hunger to pick
up the latest features
and capabilities,
and a dedication
to build beautiful
apps that engage.
In looking at your apps,
the judging panel of course
took into account
innovation and design,
but also thought about things
like app quality that actually
lead to user happiness, things
like does your app drain
battery.
None of us likes that, do we?
And judging by the ratings
and reviews on Google Play,
we are sure that our
users and your users
agree that your apps
exemplify the best that
is there in Android and Play.
So with no further ado,
let's get the show started.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Standout Indie.
Please welcome Jamil Moledina,
games strategic lead,
Google Play.
JAMIL MOLEDINA: Right
before coming to Google,
I ran an indie game startup.
I learned first hand
how risky innovation
is for a small studio.
But at the same
time, innovation may
be all you have to stand out.
It's then incumbent
upon platforms
to shine a spotlight on
those developers that
dare to try something new.
And helping operate
that spotlight at Google
is one way that I've
been able to give back
to this rich, diverse community.
Indies have inherent
value in that
they demonstrate the
endless capabilities of what
small teams can build.
They pour their hearts
and souls into their work.
They embody diversity.
And often they take
unexpected leaps,
introducing us to unique game
controls and breakthrough story
ideas, all stemming from a
deep passion for their art
while using games as a medium
to express the human condition.
This year's nominees
deliver on all counts.
Let's take a look.
ANNOUNCER: Standout
Indie nominees
are "Causality," "Kingdom--
New Lands," "Mars--
Mars," "Mushroom 11," "Reigns."
Standout Indie.
JAMIL MOLEDINA: The winner
of this year's award
is the epitome of a beautiful
game experience on mobile.
It's stunning graphics,
melancholic soundtrack,
and unique and
native game controls,
give gamers the perfect
immersion into the challenges
and outcomes of this world.
I fell in love the first time
I played the early version
of this game and I'm
thrilled that we can share it
with everyone on Google Play.
The winner of this year's
Standout Indie award
is "Mushroom 11" by Untame.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Standout Startup.
Please welcome Larissa
Fontaine, Director and Global
Head of Apps Business
development, Google Play.
LARISSA FONTAINE:
Like indies, startups
are all about taking risks
and fueling innovation.
Small and scrappy, the
most exciting startups
inspire all of us by
taking great ideas
and turning them into
breakout success stories.
At Play, we care a
lot about making sure
that startups can
find their audience
and that users can find the
great and exciting apps that
are coming from this community.
In addition to innovating
inside their own apps,
startups are often early
adopters of new platforms
and new technology
features, which
means they're creating some of
the most interesting Android
experiences today and they're
also becoming some of our best
partners.
So now that we've set
that bar really high,
let's take a look
at the nominees.
ANNOUNCER: Standout Startup
nominees are CastBox, Digit,
Discord, Hooked, Simple Habit.
Standout Startup.
LARISSA FONTAINE:
This year's winner
built an original experience
by rethinking fiction
for the texting generation.
They use an everyday
mobile behavior
to deliver creative and
captivating stories that
immerse the user in the
narrative in real time.
As a lifelong
bookworm, I'm thrilled
to announce that this year's
Standout Startup award winner
is Hooked, by Telepathic.
[APPLAUSE]
[COIN ROLLING]
[MACHINE STARTING]
[MACHINE SOUNDS]
ANNOUNCER: Best Android
Wear Experience.
Please welcome David
Singleton, VP Engineering.
DAVID SINGLETON: Android
Wear enables developers
to reach users with glanceable
information throughout the day.
And with Wear 2.0, which
is our latest release,
we introduced standalone apps.
These allow you to
build experiences
that operate independently
without necessarily requiring
the phone nearby.
The new apps being
created help simplify
life's daily activities, such
as staying informed, exploring
what's nearby, and
accessing guides and metrics
to improve your personal
health and workout routines.
And while Android Wear is still
a platform in its infancy,
we are so excited by the
support from both developers
and hardware manufacturers
and I hope more of you
will try it on.
Let's take a look at
this year's nominees.
ANNOUNCER: Best Android
Wear Experience nominees
are Bring, Foursquare, Lifesum,
Runtastic Running and Fitness,
Seven.
Best Android Wear Experience.
DAVID SINGLETON: The
winner of this year's award
offers a smart and
sleek experience
utilizing the convenience of
GPS and other key sensors.
This year's winner of best
Android Wear Experience
is Runtastic
Running and Fitness.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Best TV Experience.
Please welcome Sascha
Prueter, Director Android TV.
SASCHA PRUETER: I really
need a new stock photo.
So while many mobile
developers build
for small screen, such as
Android Wear just presented,
this category
celebrates those who
reach audiences
through Android TV
and take advantage of the
largest screen in the house.
Building for the large
screen allows developers
to explore new menu and UI
options, create rich media
experiences that drive
real long session times.
And thanks to a strong developer
community-- so thanks to you--
the TV apps section
is fast growing
and a successful category.
The number of TV apps
and placed on Android TV
have doubled since
Google I/O last year,
and it's now exceeding
3,000 apps and games.
So let's take a look at the
nominees for this year's best
TV experience.
ANNOUNCER: Best TV
Experience nominees
are AbemaTV, Haystack TV,
KKBox, Netflix, Red Bull TV.
Best TV Experience.
SASCHA PRUETER: This year's
winner has completely
updated UI to provide
a fresh, best in class,
TV user experience.
Using simple controls
and beautiful designs
they give users a content rich
offering with high quality live
and on demand content.
The winner of this
year's best TV experience
is Red Bull TV by Red Bull.
[APPLAUSE]
[NO SPEECH]
ANNOUNCER: Best VR experience.
Please welcome Clay
Bavor, VP Virtual Reality.
CLAY BAVOR: So, VR is cool
because it can, like that guy,
really make you feel like
you're somewhere else.
Whether you're on a beach
with scary crab zombies
or searching an ancient
shipwreck for VR treasure,
it really puts you
right in the action.
And you don't just
get to see what
it's like to be somewhere
else, but really experience it.
So Daydream is our platform
for mobile virtual reality.
And thanks to the
passion and creativity
of some amazing
developers, there's
a large and growing library
of really cool things
to experience and do.
You can explore
different worlds,
you can step inside
games, you can just
kick back and watch your
own personal cinema.
We've been so impressed
with what we've seen so far
and so it's my huge pleasure to
announce the nominees for best
VR experience.
ANNOUNCER: Best VR
experience nominees
are The Arcslinger,
Gunjack 2 End
of Shift, MekoramaVR, The
Turning Forest, Virtual Virtual
Reality.
Best VR experience.
CLAY BAVOR: I love them
all but the winner--
it's hard to describe
the kind of crazy,
off the wall
experience of exploring
50 different alternate realities
doing weird jobs for bored
artificial intelligences,
all while trying
to uncover the back story
of the shady company
Activitude, the virtual
labor system of the future.
You just have to try it.
The winner of this
year's best VR experience
is Virtual Virtual
Reality by Tender Claws.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Best AR experience.
Please welcome Amit Singh, VP
of Business and Operations VR.
AMIT SINGH: Hello everybody.
Just like Clay
was talking about,
Virtual reality can
take you anywhere.
Augmented Reality, AR,
can bring anything to you
as if it was there.
And we've been
working on a project
for a while called Tango.
It allows phones to
sense just like we do,
depth, scale,
perception, precision.
It can really bring objects
as if they were right there.
And people have done
amazing things with it.
You can shop for
a couch, make sure
it fits the environment you're
in, or you can invite dinosaurs
and play with them
in your kitchen.
And so let's take a
look at the nominees who
build these amazing AR
experiences powered by Tango.
ANNOUNCER: Best AR
experience nominees
are Crayola Color Blaster,
Dinosaurs Among Us, Holo,
Wayfair View, Woorld.
Best AR experience.
AMIT SINGH: Very,
very tough choice.
These are all great, you
must try and try them out.
They're all actually
in the pod over there
with the Daydream
and Tango experience.
The one that is the
winner which really brings
whimsical fanciness,
lets you be in your space
and decorate the world,
and it's just fun.
Hard to describe but
super fun to play.
And the winner is
Woorld by Funomena.
[APPLAUSE]
[NO SPEECH]
ANNOUNCER: Best app for kids.
Please welcome Shazia Makhdumi,
Global Head of Education
and Family Partnerships
Google Play.
SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: Hi everyone.
So as the mom of two
boys, aged 9 and 10,
and who are captivated
by worlds of "Harry
Potter" and "Minecraft," I
love how great apps and games
can capture kids imagination
and fire their creativity.
But in addition, the right
apps also go beyond that.
They help change parents'
perception of mobile devices
beyond electronic
babysitters to tools
that help their
kids develop skills,
to explore, to
thrive, and to learn.
Now if only someone could
build an app that keeps
my kids that same age forever.
However, developers in our
design for families program,
while they don't
do that, they use
intuitive and kid
friendly design
together with age
appropriate content
to engage and inspire kids.
With colorful characters,
creative visuals,
realistic sounds, they
build fun, educational,
and safe experiences
on mobile devices.
So this year's nominees
offer a diverse lineup
sure to appeal to any
household with kids.
Let's take a look.
ANNOUNCER: Best app for kids.
Nominees are Animal Jam Play
Wild, Hot Wheels Race Off,
Teeny Titans, Think
Think, Toca Life Vacation.
Best app for kids.
SHAZIA MAKHDUMI:
So just like it's
really hard as any
parent would know
to pick your favorite
child, you know
we've had to make a
choice here though--
love them all.
But can you imagine
anything more fun
than showing off your
style with characters
that express the real you.
This year's winner
teaches kids how
to use their creativity to
build, explore, and share,
all while learning
about science.
The winner of this
year's best app for kids
is Animal Jam Play
Wild by WildWorks.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Best
multiplayer game.
Please welcome Jason
Titus, VP of Engineering,
Developer Product Group.
JASON TITUS: So
one of the greatest
things about mobile phones is
how they let us play together
across continents and take
time, whether it's a line
or on the bus, and
actually make it
time playing with your friends.
In recent years we've
seen amazing improvements
with multiplayer
games taking advantage
of the huge numbers
of mobile users
as well as the advanced
technology in today's phones.
Multiplayer games come
in all genres and sizes,
but the thing that
they have in common
is their amazing ability
to bring us together.
A true multiplayer game is
built from the ground up,
and this year's nominees
are some of the best.
Let's take a look.
ANNOUNCER: Best multiplayer game
nominees are "Dawn of Titans,"
"FIFA Mobile," "Hearthstone,"
"Lords Mobile,"
"Modern Strike Online."
Best multiplayer game.
JASON TITUS: This year's winner
reaches a global audience
of nearly 190 countries.
It's developed by a team of 30
different nationalities, which
seems so appropriate.
To the developers continual
push for excellence
through iteration
and experimentation,
this app is constantly
evolving to make
learning one of your
favorite leisure activities--
sorry, make learning one of your
favorite leisure activities.
The winner of this year's
best multiplayer game
is Hearthstone from
Blizzard Entertainment.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Best app.
Please welcome Jamie Rosenberg,
VP, Android and Play Business.
JAMIE ROSENBERG: Hi everyone.
It's great to have
all of you here.
It's amazing to think about
the innovation in mobile apps
over the past few years.
We've seen so many
great examples of that
already tonight.
As smartphones have
become more powerful,
you all have kept pace
by finding more ways
for our phones to help
us in our daily lives.
Great apps help us
create, explore, stay
fit, organize, learn,
and so much more.
The very best of these
do so through excellence
in design and performance,
thoughtful use
of the capabilities
of our devices,
and often a bit of fun.
Let's take a look at the
nominees for best app.
ANNOUNCER: Best app nominees are
Citymapper, Fabulous, Memrise,
Money Lover, Quik.
Best app.
JAMIE ROSENBERG: So I'm just
going to cut to the chase.
This app takes an activity
that can be a drag and makes it
a ton of fun.
The Google Play award for
best app goes to Memrise.
[APPLAUSE]
[NO SPEECH]
ANNOUNCER: Best game.
Please welcome Sameer
Samat, VP, Play and Android.
SAMEER SAMAT: I've
been playing games
on smartphones for
a very long time,
and I think we can
all agree that games
have come a long way on mobile.
It's exciting to
see so many of you
using the capabilities
of the platform
to build amazing experiences.
You're helping to change
the way people think
about mobile gaming, by
presenting rich storylines,
mindblowing graphics,
and bringing out
the competitor in each of us.
With two billion
Android devices,
developers have the
freedom to build
fun and engaging experiences
knowing that an audience is
just one tap away.
Let's take a look at
this year's nominees.
ANNOUNCER: Best game nominees
are "Choices," "Fire Emblem
Heroes," "Lineage 2 Revolution,"
"Pokemon Go," "Transformers
Forged to Fight."
Best game.
SAMEER SAMAT: Now all of
these titles are inspiring.
This year's winner brings
console quality graphics
to mobile, showcasing
gaming on Android.
Through stunning 3D graphics
and incredible technical
performance, they're bringing
iconic characters to life
and offering an inspiration
for what gaming can truly
be on mobile.
The winner of this
year's best game award
is "Transformers
Forged to Fight."
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Best
accessibility experience.
Please welcome
Hiroshi Lockheimer,
SVP Platforms and Ecosystems.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
How's everyone doing?
Having fun?
That's good.
Before we get to this, I just
want to say a quick thank you.
Android, Google Play, we
would be nowhere without you.
So a big thank you to
the developer community.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Well at Google, our mission
is to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful,
Universally accessible.
So with this mission in mind
and that phrase in mind,
it's with great
pleasure that I get
to introduce this new category,
best accessibility experience.
Here we will
highlight developers
that offer innovative
solutions to assist users
with different
accessibility needs
in overcoming common challenges.
They deliver
intuitive experiences,
empower individuals
through mobile apps,
they foster communication,
build independence,
and have the capability
of connecting users
in very meaningful ways.
So let's take a look
at the nominees.
ANNOUNCER: Best accessibility
experience nominees
are A Blind Legend,
Eye-D, IFTTT, Open
Sesame, Swiftkey Symbols.
Best accessibility experience.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: All right.
Well the winner of
this year's award
is a brilliantly
designed platform
offering experience inclusive
for users and developers
with various needs.
They simplify daily
tasks, especially
for those with vision
and motor impairments,
to increase productivity
and independence.
Please join me in congratulating
this year's winner of this best
accessibility experience, IFTTT.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Best social impact.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
It's me again.
I'm back.
You know, I was hoping
for my head shot again
but you'll get it live instead.
OK, so developer ecosystem has
an extremely diverse makeup.
The product of this breadth
of culture, personal interest,
and creative vision, produces
a lot of truly amazing work.
You make a lot of amazing work.
Thank you.
This category
looks for apps that
create meaningful social impact
for a broad spectrum of people
around the world, while taking
full advantage of the platform.
It rewards developers who
challenge themselves to promote
themes of contribution,
accessibility, and knowledge
sharing, through creative
solutions that address issues
locally, regionally,
and even globally.
So let's take a look
at the nominees.
ANNOUNCER: Best
social impact nominees
are, Charity Miles, Peek
Acuity, ProDeaf, Sea Hero Quest,
ShareTheMeal.
Best social impact.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
This year's winner
generates large scale reach
to fight a major global issue.
The app uses a simple
interface to drive
awareness and engagement
of a major cause.
They are a tremendous partner
and I encourage you all
to try out their new
instant app launching here
at I/O. The winner of this
year's best social Impact award
is ShareTheMeal.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Please welcome
back Purnima Kochikar.
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: What an
amazing lineup, isn't it?
One more time, give a big
hand to all the nominees
and the winners.
[APPLAUSE]
I echo Hiroshi when
he said, without you,
our tools and our
platforms are nothing.
So we thank you for
your commitment,
for your innovation, and I
can't wait to see you here
next year to see what you
would have built between now
and then.
So thank you all for coming.
I hope you enjoy the
rest of the show.
There's a big show at
the amphitheater at 8:00.
We hope to see you there.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]